y'all I might have to sell my love
kidney to make an egg sandwich thanks to
the avian flu so I decided to find the
best egg substitute first we got just
egg it's the easiest to find and retails
around 3.99 for eight servings it's got
a good structure to it but had a little
Funk when I realized it was made of
chickpeas though it made sense and I
could see myself using it in the future
I found the sparrow Pepita egg
alternative for 449 for seven servings
despite looking a little freaky it was
surprisingly soft and fluffy and had a
really nice eggy flavor good and gather
makes a liquid egg substitute for 5.79
for 20 servings of Steel I was wondering
how it tasted so realistic and then
realize it has egg whites in it but
while it contains eggs it's still an
amazing price lastly I got these boiled
wonder eggs for 7.99 for three eggs so
clearly I took an L on this financially
even though it tasted pretty realistic I
don't want to Shell out like that am I
right all that being said good and
gather give some great bang for your
buck and tastes good despite not having
egg yolk in it otherwise I'd say the
sparrow eggs are the most delicious
eggless option hope this helps and best
of luck to all my fellow egg lovers